my channel is sponsored by athletic
greens which means we will hear more
from them somewhere in the middle of the
video hello everyone i'm alana and
welcome to my channel where today i
wanted to talk about something that i
have spoken about before on the channel
uh but this is basically going to be an
extension of that because we have more
information and this was inspired by a
recent chat that i had on the channel um
an interview with the founder of
devolverdigital his name is mike wilson
about his new company deepwell and
basically like that sparked me to want
to just kind of talk about this more
it's something that people don't talk
about a whole lot because
while it is very serious and i think
very important um
it's not a flashy headline it's not
something people want to talk about on
youtube so
we're basically going to be talking
about the relationship between mental
health and video games and some of the
new studies that have come out
uh effectively proving that uh games can
depending on the kind of game the kind
of person and the kind of
you know illness i suppose um
can assist
and provide a lot of mental health
benefits to the extent that
what deepwell is doing i'll leave a link
in the description to the interview this
is in no way in partnership with
deepwell or anything like that i just
think what they're doing is very cool
um they are looking to get games
actually classified in ways that pertain
to specific mental illnesses so for
example you could have
a logo on on the front of something just
like you have the pegi 18 rating or
whatever that would say this is
certified
as a treatment or an assistance for
people who have depression or anxiety um
and they would actually rate games
medically rate them which i think is
such a good idea considering how much
games have helped me so
before we get into sharing some of the
science or some of the more recent
studies that i haven't spoken about here
um i just wanted to share my story which
i have done here before
but not in a very long time and uh it's
now with a little bit more substance
because it's not just anecdotal so
for anyone who hasn't heard this before
and solely with the interest of helping
i
had depression from the age of about 19
as something that i dealt with on and
off um
and it was
to me the way that i would describe
depression
common misconception is people think
that it is sadness i don't think that i
ever really felt sad what i felt was an
absolute absence of self um a depression
in a very literal sense that it was
depressive all parts of me were just
pulled down and and numbed and and made
dull um and cold and empty that is
the way that i
felt
and i
had a lot of trouble with figuring out
how to get out of it um or even with
registering that it was there i don't
think i actually knew that i
was dealing with something that was in
any level serious until i was living
home my mom came into my room one day
and she was like why haven't you got out
of bed and it was like 4pm
and i said why
and i said that without
any
aggression i wasn't trying to argue with
her i just did not see any purpose
to get out of bed that day um
it is time to talk about ag-1 by
athletic greens 81 by athletic greens is
a daily supplement that you've probably
seen me use on streams well before they
asked me to make this sponsorship
segment i love it because as a person
who is very busy very easy for me to let
my health be the thing that drops off
when everything else is ramping up and
ag-1 tastes good is very easy to drink
and has
75 different ingredients including
vitamins minerals superfoods probiotics
all the good stuff that it's just so
easy to miss out on if you're getting
sick more often than you'd like to it's
totally possible that that's happening
because you aren't getting the right
vitamins and minerals ag-1 has vitamin c
zinc and healing mushrooms all to
support your immunity but the thing that
i felt the biggest effects from and that
appeals to me the most personally is
what it does for my energy levels your
body's supposed to be getting these
nutrients and it's not in a lot of the
food that we eat so i for sure notice
that when i have my ag-1 i have more
mental clarity and i seem to be able to
work out better all very good stuff for
your body that again it's just so easy
to miss out on and i really don't think
we prioritize enough and i guess the
reason that it's stuck with me for so
long and is something that's very easy
to recommend is that it's just so easy
to use all you need is one scoop or
travel packet of ag1 and eight ounces of
water every day so go to athletic
greens.com alana pierce to get started
on your order athletic greens is going
to give my community a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase thanks to athletic greens
for sponsoring the video now back to the
video and i again no anger i wasn't
crying i just
just my whole life was very static
and um
then i was like [ __ ]
i that sorry she was like okay you have
depression you're depressed i've seen
this before we need to do something
about it so she helped me
uh or got me help and
it's something that um
can be very challenging to deal with on
your own or or seem impossible and the
trouble with figuring out that you have
it and trying to get rid of it my
picture is like you're a person holding
a little light bulb
and everything else is black
and dark and the night and it's just
coming in on you all the time and you're
just trying to keep this one little
light bulb of light and and the fog is
just so intense and so thick
that the only thing you have is this
tiny little light that you're holding
staring at and just trying to
to keep but when the fog covers your
whole body you know it it's so cheesy
but it's genuine i'm very vividly
explaining this emotion to you
you're just covered in this fog and it's
weighing you down like a just a heavy
wet blanket
and you're trying to see the light and
it just keeps fading and fading and
fading and there's nothing that you know
that you can do like maybe if you stood
up then it would light up the whole room
but you don't know that um and that's a
real problem with a lot of rhetoric that
pertains to
just do something is that
you have no motivation to do anything
you have no motivation that so exercise
helps me more than anything is the
biggest thing um with
depression but the problem is to get
yourself to exercise and i now know that
so when i have had other bouts of
depression or something that i know now
that that um i'm susceptible to i've not
had it in a very long time but the last
time that i had was about seven years
ago
i moved from australia to the us
and i got a job at ign
uh and as i was waiting
well context there is i left everyone i
had ever known i had no friends no
family nothing i left every human i had
ever had a conversation with basically
um and moved continents very far away
different time zone different culture
you deal with culture shock
a lot happened and i was waiting for my
health insurance um as a new employee i
joined in november and the way that
insurance works in the us is like
something around that time of year
basically i didn't have insurance when i
first moved and i was trying to get that
figured out and i
was also trying to work very hard
because i was at a new company um and i
got sick
and it was the flu
um
like proper influenza
and
because
i really wanted to be in the office and
get to know the new people that i was
around and just be head first in this
job and
you know trying to avoid dealing with
missing my family or whatever else
i kept working
um i went to convention in las vegas
called ces the consumer electronics show
i believe it stands for
and um
because i just overworked when i was
already sick i
got pneumonia uh so
you know i started to feel like there
was liquid in my chest every breath i
could literally feel liquid just moving
up and down my lungs basically
um
it was very gross and a really shitty
thing to deal with it makes you feel
like like you're going to die and people
do die from pneumonia it
sucks so i went to the doctor and
i was given two options um
one of them was stay in the hospital for
a small amount of time but it was very
expensive
the other was
stay home
for i don't remember i think it was 10
days
take this medicine sleep as much as you
can
and
because i was running to work to avoid
the homesickness that i was feeling and
all the change that had happened in my
life and just a shock of everything
the fact that i was now very sick
again just pneumonia the uh the killer
is it's so hard to sleep because you
can't breathe
just
an awful feeling um
you just constantly have to cough or
feel
like there is just a wetness inside of
your lungs it's just
oh it's super gross it's awful so uh
i
then just couldn't sleep
they put me on codeine um my cough
medicine had coating in it to to help
but that period was
me the thing i was using as an escape
was now cut off for me because i had to
rest so that i didn't you know die of
pneumonia um
and that was my worst nightmare so
as that was happening and i was getting
sicker and i was staying in anyway and
then eventually got the pneumonia just
had to stay from home for 10 days i
definitely felt like i was back in the
hall of depression and i could feel it
coming at the the period of i don't want
to do anything there's nothing i want to
do i don't want to go anywhere i don't
want to talk to anyone i don't want to
see anyone
this is the worst um
i have no motivation to live is very
much how it feels again and not in a way
that i was ever suicidal just in a way
that you don't
have the spark of life it doesn't exist
the passion is gone you just exist you
just wake up and then wait to go to
sleep at least again that's how it was
for me
the thing that i think genuinely
saved me from
falling into a much deeper well of
depression um and having it stick with
me the way that it did when i first had
depression
was a video game called the witness by
jonathan blood
the witness is i think expertly designed
regardless of my circumstance um but i
believe it had just come out it was like
around february
uh came out on playstation i'm pretty
sure ps4 february
2016. i might be wrong i think it's in
that window
that game just came out and one of my
roommates was playing it um
and we ended up effectively just playing
it together it might have been the other
way around i may have been the one to
stop playing and she joined me but that
became the thing that i looked forward
to i had something that was mentally
stimulating me
that was extremely challenging but in
small enough doses that i had the
capacity to take it because i was so
sleepy because i was on codeine
so you know you walk into the witness
and it is a game where you have to solve
puzzles without any tutorial the puzzles
themselves are the tutorial you see a
puzzle you have to think about what it
could mean you effectively have to
translate it yourself
figure out how to solve the puzzle
and there are so many different kinds of
them um in this beautiful very peaceful
bright colorful
environment so
i was waking up
i was super sick i couldn't go anywhere
i couldn't i couldn't really see anyone
i wasn't allowed to drive because you
can't when you're on codeine um
i i was miserable but there was this
beautiful bright
colorful um
very peaceful sound design
video game that wasn't overly
overwhelming it wasn't like it was a
platformer where i was failing all the
time it was something that i could take
my own time with and and absorb at my
own pace and so many different kinds of
puzzles like i said so it was like i
would find an area and i would finish
that
in a day that pertain to one particular
puzzle type and then the next day you
know we would start again and play for a
few hours and move on to the next puzzle
type and then just keep going
it fully got me through it it
was peaceful relaxing mentally
stimulating gave me a sense of purpose
gave me a sense of accomplishment where
i think the absolute lack of sense of
accomplishment when you're very sick and
you're away from you know every
relationship you've built
can really weigh on you and i fully
credit the witness for
uh me being able to get out of that
actually quite quickly comparatively i
was probably only two months whereas
previously it was something that i had
for well over a year and it just like
that year of my life effectively doesn't
exist just complete static
um i ended up drinking a lot when i had
it the first time too because i was
19 i'm pretty sure 19.
and it leads to just a lot of
bad things that you don't really know
how to do because at least like i think
part of it is that um i wouldn't have
considered myself to be an alcoholic who
wasn't drinking that often but i was
binge drinking so i was getting drunk i
wasn't just having a glass of wine
because it was something i felt like i
could have control over
it was something to do
it was something that changed my
emotional status
and it makes sense why people when
they are depressed can lean into
substance abuse for sure
um again i don't think anybody would
have called me an alcoholic but it
certainly was a behavior that i've never
done at any other point in my life um
but yes i really strongly feel like the
witness helped and then there have been
periods like more recently where i had
something a few years ago maybe it was
during kobe something i was sad about
something i don't remember what and i
finished abzu just a peaceful game where
you
have companions in the ocean and there
are so many games like this that we
don't talk about enough that can help
so so much in so many different ways so
that is my story um and i feel very
strongly about it and i've tried to
advocate for the relationship between
mental health and video games as much as
i can since then
but
and i mean i would love to hear you guys
share stories as well this is not
something that i'm telling for the first
time right now but i probably am telling
it with more
detail right now um i've
definitely gotten more candid with the
way that i speak
on youtube so
i would love to hear your stories i
would love to hear video games that have
helped you i feel very strongly about it
but yeah i also just wanted to like cite
some actual articles to actually talk
about some of this if this is something
that any of you maybe have non-gamers in
your life and you want to talk to them
about it
let's get the information as well
because i think it's super cool so let's
do that
okay so this article is from the
american psychological association
hang on let me pull my camera up real
quick
it says a video gameplay may provide
learning help social benefits review
fine so uh what i did was reach out to a
bunch of doctors that i now know through
my time working in the games industry
and have them recommend me some articles
or some talking points i was gonna do
this like full interview thing but uh i
realized that would probably be a little
bit too
time consuming that i might break that
out into like a separate series where i
repeatedly do that
um
but yes this one is from the american
psychological association and was sent
to me by a friend who is a doctor so it
says
playing video games including violent
shooter games which is a super
interesting part may boost children's
learning health and social skills
according to a review of research in
american psychologists this is otherwise
known as apa.org the study comes out as
debate continues among psychologists and
other health professionals regarding the
effects of violent media on youth an apa
task force is conducting a comprehensive
review of research on violence in video
games and interactive media and will
release its findings later this year i
should actually follow up on that this
is pretty old so
i'm sure it's been updated
important research has already been
conducted for decades on the negative
effects of gaming a lot including
addiction depression and aggression and
we are certainly not suggesting that
this should be ignored which i also
think is fair
uh however to understand the impact of
video games on children and adolescence
development a more balanced perspective
is needed
while one widely held view maintains
that playing video games is
intellectually lazy strongly disagree
such play actually may strengthen a
range of cognitive skills such as facial
navigation reasoning memory and
perception according to several studies
reviewed in the article
this is particularly true for shooter
video games which are often violent
authors found and those are the ones
that i feel like you know get the bad
rap in video a 2013 meta analysis found
that playing shooter video games
improved a a player's capacity to think
about objects in three dimensions just
as well as academic courses designed to
enhance these same skills which is super
[ __ ] cool and makes a lot of sense
the fact that
you playing
cod or whatever
can improve your ability to think about
objects inside of dimensions just as
much as a course designed to do that
that's so cool uh this has critical
implications for education and career
development as previous research has
established the power of spatial skills
for achievement in science technology
engineering and mathematics
it's also
uh this enhanced thinking was not found
when playing other types of video games
such as puzzles or role-playing games
which i think makes sense you need to be
more
spatially aware when you have a threat
um i always say i could still draw the
house from resident evil 7 i could still
draw out that first house i think
i haven't played it since the game came
out and i still think i could draw it
perfectly i just became so spatially
aware of that house and every room i had
to run into to avoid jack
uh playing video games may also help
children develop problem-solving skills
authors said the more adolescents
reported playing strategic video games
such as role-playing games the more they
improved in problem-solving and school
grades the following year according to a
long-term study published in 2013.
children's creativity was also enhanced
by playing any kind of video game
including violent games
uh i guess that's actually why this one
was linked to me specifically i didn't
want to cite any of the doctors that i
spoke to just because i didn't ask them
for permission
but um i think they wanted to send me
this one
because they said that there were
positive effects of violent video games
specifically
um
yeah but didn't happen when children use
other forms of technology such as a
computer or a cell phone
it does require a lot of focus too i
wonder if it can help with um problem
solving that kind of case
sample games that are easy to access and
can be played quickly such as angry
birds can improve players moods promote
relaxation and ward off anxiety the
study set if playing video games simply
makes people happier this seems to be a
fundamental emotional benefit to
consider and
i agree
the authors also highlighted the
possibility that video games are
effective tools for learning resilience
in the face of failure
golden ring
by learning to cope with ongoing
failures in games the authors suggest
that children build emotional resilience
they can rely upon in their everyday
lives that is super cool
another stereotype the research
challenges is the socially isolated
gamer more than 70 percent of gamers
play with a friend wow
it's probably even higher than that now
and millions of people worldwide
participate in a massive virtual world
sorry in massive virtual worlds through
video games such as farmville and world
of warcraft multiplayer games become
virtual social communities where
decisions need to be made quickly about
whom to trust or reject and how to lead
a group the authors set people who play
video games even if they are violent
that encourage corporation are more
likely to be helpful to others while
gaming than those who play the same
games competitively
hell
yes
okay so this one is from very
wellmind.com and goes more specifically
into the mental health benefits of video
games rather than um
learning um and this is uh also from
2021 so says think video games or
entertainment it might just be time to
take a look at the second a second look
at this popular hobby
uh a report published in the journal
jmir series games reviewed research on
the impact of commercial video games on
depression anxiety and other mental
health concerns it found that there's
mounting scientific evidence supporting
the potential for video games to improve
mental health outcomes especially for
people who can't access other types of
treatment due to cost or location
that could give the world's 2.7 billion
gamers opportunity for major emotional
wellness benefits and again i especially
think if what deepwell intends to do
pays off which is
effectively like license certain games
license is the wrong word but but um
confirm
i'm forgetting what the word i'm looking
for is obviously
to establish
like medically
certain games as being treatments for
certain mental health problems that is
so much more accessible than current
mental health services so much more
accessible not only do you have the
barrier of often having to find a
therapist or psychiatrist and then find
one you like um find one who's in your
insurance network which is so
complicated like there's so many layers
to that it's also daunting because of
the person that you have to talk to and
that experience and while i want to
encourage anybody who needs to to get
therapy or to see a psychiatrist or
psychologist i really do want to
encourage you to do that and try to do
it and know that it is worth it that is
self-care that is you loving yourself
going through the effort to do that and
it will make your life better it's
really [ __ ] hard and i understand why
a lot of people don't do it and why they
find it so daunting
if you're someone who's depressed or has
anxiety or has anger issues and you are
interested in bettering yourself
it can be so much easier to find one of
these games that is rated for whatever
your particular issue is or whatever
your particular feeling is
and play it as a treatment
so much easier it's so accessible um it
also like takes
all of the gross income away from
just medicine just from everything being
prescribed as medicine what if we can
prescribe video games instead like i
love that uh our video games the future
of mental health treatment here's what
the latest research research
shows
for this report researchers from liro
the science foundation island research
center for software looked at earlier
studies to see whether commercial video
games not just specialized therapeutic
games which of course do also exist
could fill in existing gaps in mental
health treatment particularly for
depression and anxiety the research
found evidence that video games could
help alleviate symptoms of depression
such as the loss of pleasure like i said
depression is an absolute numbing
uh that was definitely my experience
video games minecraft and animal
crossing new horizons also fostered
social connectedness and reduced
loneliness
that's awesome
video games provide connection a
critical aspect of mental health feeling
like you're part of a community of
like-minded people who value your
participation and share your goal within
the game says glenn platt phd professor
of emerging technology and director of
the interactive media studies program at
miami university in ohio isolation as
the author's outline plays a significant
role in the anxiety and sorry in anxiety
and depressive disorders
the support of a community within a game
ecosystem mitigates this that
is not a thing i had even thought about
certain video games provide mood
regulation benefits as well in one study
adolescents who played mario kart had
better emotional regulation skills than
peers who didn't play the game and that
makes a lot of sense video games could
be used as therapeutic distraction that
could help regulate moods reduce
rumination and even evoke joy for sure
studies reviewed by the researchers also
showed that video games can help address
and treat symptoms of anxiety in one
experiment people with anxiety who play
the tower defense game plants vs zombies
four times a week for at least a half
hour each session experienced better
mental health outcomes than those who
took medication
that's nuts
in some experiments video games like max
and the magic marker were also shown to
prevent
elevated anxiety in kids
uh as a licensed professional counselor
and professional game sorry personal
gamer myself i am ecstatic to see more
research studies and resources such as
this one start proliferating around
serious psychological discussions says
drew lightfoot lpc clinical director at
thrivebox philadelphia the study is
correct when it states that video games
can be used to help effectively treat
anxiety depression and social anxiety
commercial video games versus therapy
games yeah there is a whole world of um
therapy games
which i guess have
some
detractors
people have more desire to play
commercial video games is what it is
that makes sense yeah that they're not
necessarily going to be successful
because we don't have a ton of
compulsion to play them
the problem with bespoke video games
like brain games is that they generally
aren't really games when you are told to
click on things on the screen to improve
your mental health that is also not a
game it is a therapy
he continues a critical quality of a
game what makes it a game is that it is
played voluntarily research has
repeatedly validated the importance of
intrinsic motivation for effective
behavior change
that makes a ton of sense
which is what leads us to the critical
insight from this article that people
play commercial video games because they
want to
and i played a lot of games when i was
depressed uh the first time as well
and as such the beneficial aspects of
these games in terms of anxiety and
depression are bestowed as a byproduct
of their fun and not the outcome of
their game homework
that is awesome
um
video games may expand
access to care is a thing that i think i
already sort of touched on
a fair bit but i'll leave a link in the
description to this particular article
just because that's a ton of detail
that's i don't know i just think very
exciting uh that was also sent to me by
one of the doctors i spoke to i just i
think it's very very cool i know this is
largely me reading articles that other
people suggested that i read but it's
something that i always want to shine a
light on if like
if you need help think about the games
you're playing think about what you can
do to choose games that may be able to
assist you a little bit further
i always
want to suggest you work out dry oculus
mata as it's now called metaquest beat
saber try um switch sports just came out
uh try
um
the fitness game i'm forgetting what
it's called the switch
fitness game
completely forgetting what it's called
but it's also um very good i also was
thinking about starting to do something
uh where while i'm playing a game on
stream for every death i like do
some weightlifting because i thought
that might be a good way to get other
people involved in trying to just
you know video games is good for your
brain also do stuff for your body and
and they make it so much they give you
so much more incentive like walking on a
treadmill for an hour is really boring i
get why people don't want to do it
but if you compare that i used to play
gears before multiplayer so i paired it
um
it makes it feel way less like a chore
and more even like a reward so
just something i wanted to talk about
always want to talk about always want to
highlight be mindful of your needs and
if you're a gamer think of how
certain games may be able to serve those
needs uh if you feel anxious find a game
that provides you a safe space or a
happy place or somewhere to calm down
depression i would definitely go for
things that give you a sense of
accomplishment that give you that
feeling of joy that is otherwise always
missing um definitely always try to
exercise if you can seriously please
it's the one thing that helped me and
and nutrition
the things that helped me like really
more than anything else um but video
games definitely help when you aren't
able to do those things for any reason
like me where i had pneumonia i couldn't
work out so
video games were the savior there um if
anyone else has any other suggestions i
would love to hear them
just something i'm always super happy to
talk about so that's pretty much it for
me today thank you all for watching
i will see you guys next time bye